43 to the Walker head he hits seven
threes in that game he likes playing
against the guy with the basketball
right now
Kyrie Irving games per shot off the
window and in you don't have plays runs
for you as a youth vested as a player
you have to figure out ways to get your
points to get to the free-throw line as
a rookie it's hard to figure out
we're being in a hurry tipping the cap
give credit where credit is due that was
a big time move for Kyrie red head of
Steve look at the sweet move right there
zero change it to the left take the hit
carrier make it tiny is darting dwayne
bacon on the defensive end and chemists
gotta find and quickly on the defense
types a head of the pack we can't find
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the assistant Khatri urban Billy knew he
was going to love it to it when I put it
on the right side around us it will help
Billy gets it he gets in the back I can
get the friendly roll it back you always
talk about the strength of his dancer
his fingers on the left side twice he's
gonna block that shot 8.24 last time
these two teams met double w tim course
you don't
slide this up strong drive around a
couple of guys to Yale the body contact
ice giveaway we're gonna have an urban
has made seven shots in ten minutes
Kimball leaves with seven points next to
his name cut pass picked off by Boston
when they're open and half-time Robert
Williams back in to play center for
Boston
that could score low in it he's just
trying to find different ways right now
to make shots they better have a great
recognition new Boris is right behind
him had to be careful
[Applause]
if welcome perforce knew he was going to
go right he just could not beat only got
to make the three the start those wins
you've just got [ __ ]
[Applause]
he makes that shot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
three even twice Jason Tatum's Marcus
four to five on the floor for Bob Miller
Beck
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight for Kyrie Irving ready-made
deeply boy files bridges roads our
bridges
[Applause]
J the work there bound the rookie breaks
up the alley and then I'll let us stop
the default movement right there he gets
behind the defense attorneys real well
over the last she can add another three
points to the captain Sanger too far
back double fault lost it inside
slept on the hand after the turn over to
the left side of your screen coming in
right now
land with the clip
[Music]
typical Finnish
[Music]
[Applause]
so Todd
[Music]
feller
Kyrie Irving
Showtime
you talk about voting for holiday
especially this time of the year late in
the year as it is again on her backs
down screen in the 12 games inflate the
zero value there I mean look at his
teammates he kept his ability
for the missing games they can still be
Christendom's marvin williams into the
corner for dwayne bacon exactly three
minutes left
[Applause]
tandem
[Applause]
or off stars one end Kairi little
hesitation there look at the spin I'll
get this ball and hang on the rim and
fall through
[Applause]
come on tell
[Applause]